well new research says children of
working mothers are just as happy later
in life as the kids of stay-at-home moms
you 71% of employed women in the US have
children ages 18 and younger a new study
led by a Harvard University professor
found daughters of working moms are more
likely to advance in their own careers
and when the sons of working moms
started their own families they spent 50
minutes more each week caring for them
CBS News contributor Jody canter is a
correspondent for the New York Times
Jody you're also a mother of two and
your youngest daughter Violet is here in
the green room with you a perfect
example of you juggling two different
jobs because violet normally doesn't
come with you know that guy yeah tell us
more about what this research shows
because it makes me relieved obviously
my mother a working mother as well and
and she's relieved too a lot of mothers
out there are well in some ways it
confirms what intuitively we've already
known in our own lives which is that
these kids turn out just fine but the
headline in certain ways is actually
what happens to the sons of working
mothers because it turns out that this
has a transformative effect on their
lives not so much on their employment
but on their personal lives on who they
choose as a partner and the time they
spend in their own household and with
their own kids because they see in
mirror what their mother does right and
they respect a woman who can be a mom at
home for them obviously but also they
respect what she does during the day
they tend to conduct much more equitable
home lives when they become adults and
there's the relations with young women
who choose to work outside the home they
have if their mother worked outside the
home they tend to do that more - is that
right and that's also the pattern in
general at large I mean this is tracking
a generational change in which women
have flooded into the workplace and the
matter of working outside the home is a
matter of choice but also necessity when
a mother leaves her children to work
she's providing for those children she's
taking care of them just in a different
way than she would be by staying at home
but Jody mom Guild's is a real thing I
think that if you're a working mother
and you see mothers who are staying at
home you're thinking well maybe they
have a the kids are better off because
mom is home all day and you certainly
feel judged and sometimes in a negative
way
what did the study say about that well I
would line I would well first of all it
it offered some relief and said
essentially don't feel so guilty but
what I would also say is that parent
guilt is a real thing and so much of so
much of gender progress is about
equitably sharing both the joys and the
burdens of life and what we see in our
reporting is that men feel much more
guilty about lose leaving their kids
this is a generation reared on paternity
leave and the men I interview in the
workplace they feel a real tug to be
with their children as well but for
working moms your kids turn out okay
do they not I mean I study indicate that
that is what the study indicates exactly
it's essentially saying to women you
know it may hurt to leave your child at
home when you're leaving for the work
day but there's no evidence showing that
this is actually gonna have a
deleterious effect on who they become it
may even help them and say I don't know
about you but I'm sure you do with your
fascinating job and the world-changing
work that you're doing but you talk to
your kids about what you do right I mean
they have this level of respect for moms
really doing something that's
groundbreaking well you know I'm not
sure that you know one of the funny
things about living through the last
year of reporting is that you know well
their age not age-appropriate honest
that little violet have no idea who
Harvey Weinstein was your kids can
overcome an escape because they they
don't know or care about your work but I
think yes it's true that that you're
teaching them so much about well they do
see your awards at home that I see I
think she's playing with the Emmys out
there well then we should put because
they're very pointy those Emmys so don't
let her play with them too much
Jody always good to have you at the
table and violets first day at CBS this
morning welcome violet